how to sell your idea if you don't have
the money to build it so I got a great
question from one of my YouTube fans
love you guys who wrote in to say this
is the island monster and he said I've
been watching the Shark Tank episodes
I've seen so many inventions and so many
ideas and they're really great but I
have an idea that will sell and if I
invent it it won't cost a lot but I'm
sure it will solve really good so my
question is how to show your idea and
invent it if you don't have that money
to build it and who can help you build
it if you don't have the money to build
it by the way thank you for your video
help a lot okay Island monster
great question and one that a lot of
inventors go through so this is a
chronic problem for a lot of inventors
right you have a great idea you don't
have the money to build it up yourself
but you know that they could do really
well in the market so your first step is
you have to protect your idea you need
to get a patent and the first step is a
provisional patent and then your full-on
patent if you don't have a patent then
if you go out and you go talk to a big
company they're just gonna take your
idea and use it themselves right there's
no reason why they need to pay you I
don't know what your idea is but whoever
you're gonna sell this idea to whatever
big corporation they're gonna look at it
and say that's a great idea
and if you don't have the patent they're
just gonna say okay team run with it
there's no reason to pay you for right
they're trying to maximize their profits
that doesn't include paying you so you
need to get the patent to protect your
idea so that's first first step second
part is to actually go out and sell this
to them they need to see something right
the closer you have to a finished
product the easier it is to understand
what it is that you do and the benefit
but you want to try to avoid just having
an idea on paper right you're thinking
what is the Minimum Viable Product right
what is the the minimum I need to show
them that this thing will work but they
don't necessarily expect you to have a
degree in industrial design and it to be
perfect but they need to understand that
it can work for them right so what is
the minimum that you need to create so
you can show them that your invention
will help them that's what they need to
see and it could be you
jerry-rigging something in your basement
but if you don't have the technical
skills to do it a great option is to go
to a local college or university and
tell them here's what you're trying to
do find one of their classes and often
they are looking for projects to help
out on right just just for experience
right the students need classes that's
any projects for their classes and they
have a lot of experience and they'd love
to make it a real-world project that
they can then add to their resume to say
hey I worked with XYZ inventor company
makes it look good on the resume so
again number one get the patent you need
to protect yourself you need to protect
the idea if you really believe this is
something that will take off and then
number two you have to show you have to
show me something right show me that
this thing will work just a minimum
level so that I can understand the
concept and see yes I think this is a
good idea or not and that could be you
building it yourself an early prototype
or getting the help of students to help
you build this thing up that's my advice
believe those you guys watching thumbs
up below let me know what you would do
if you're an inventor I'd love to hear
how you have gotten your product to
market leave it in the comments below
and if you guys want to see more videos
like this click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon